okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because i am joined by lake bell and
sarah cooper who star in summering which
is in theaters today how you guys doing
today
great steve thank you oh thank you for
joining me i absolutely love this film
and my first question is actually for
lake lake you have such a strong resume
now of directing shout out pam and tommy
those two episodes directed awesome but
is there a director's mindset that you
constantly have running even when you're
acting in a film like this or is that
hard to turn off
such a good question
yeah
i definitely um
you know james and i are like sundance
colleagues at this point you know like
we're both um you know i admire him as a
as a filmmaker as well and i think um
honestly the way that i learned to make
movies and to direct was being in the
trenches so long as an actor and to
sponge and respectfully observe
the things that i needed in order to to
take on cinematic storytelling so um
it's really important in my
process to continue to show up on other
people's sets and to be
a respectful observer and then being
like oh what are you putting on there
okay you're shooting mostly
okay so 45 is your workhorse okay so
what are you gonna throw you know but i
don't i don't i really enjoy coming in
and allowing for
i want to participate in someone else's
vision i just do
because i think that acting is just an
extension of storytelling it's just
you're one of the
you're one of the components to help
this person erect a vision and so i
love being a part of it from all angles
yeah and i love that you can tap in and
out all those angles and wear different
hats it's really awesome that you're
doing that your career just keeps
growing and growing awesome now
sarah what's really cool is this your
first feature film acting wise is this
something you always dreamed of
happening or is this kind of also taking
you a little bit by like shock
i mean i always dreamed of doing this i
i wanted to be an actor when i was
little ever since i was told i couldn't
sing
um and then i was like you know what i'm
gonna act
so i decided i wanted to be an actor but
i'm com come from an immigrant family
and they were like uh no we're not
paying for a theater degree for you um
so i had this sort of
bouncing back and forth between the
corporate world and acting and
was really trying to be an actress and
and was really struggling with it and
really wanted to find my voice so then i
did stand-up comedy and i did that for a
long time i was really focusing on
comedy but i always wanted to act that
was what i always wanted to do and so to
try stand up for 10 years go through a
pandemic make a tick tock that blew up
that actually led me back to acting is
like a wild experience that i'm like who
wrote this you know what i mean god is
like the best writer because you never
see it coming you never see the plot
twist coming and it's amazing but i'm
i'm i'm thrilled i'm just thrilled to to
be a part of it like lake said it's like
a story that you want to be a part of
and um yeah
i and i love all these different things
we see you do too it's like you step up
and you deliver each time you do here in
the film so really exciting and
lake having your main scene partner in
this film being a kid
is there anything you learn from that
experience is that kind of also just a
wild thing
i think um
i mean this is like the
the director in me knows to show up and
meet a a
a younger actor child actor kind of toe
to toe and not try to dumb down anything
just being really present and even as a
mom you know it's like there's no baby
talk you know it's like there's no
dumbing down anything it's sort of
you are
she's a professional you know it's like
leah was a professional and she showed
up knowing her [ __ ] and so that's how
i do her the the i treat her with
respect and the way that she's treating
me with respect and so we we arrive
together especially because the
character
you know i'm sort of
um
i'm parentalizing her in many ways you
know inadvertently and so we both show
up and i'm kind of like i'm your equal
even though of course that that
intrinsically is like the problem with
their relationship you know so i think
um for this particular role it was it
was
it behooved me to show up in a way that
was very um equal
yeah and i love that it just translated
on screen with lauren daisy's
relationship it's a really interesting
relationship in the film and is what
makes great films and it definitely is
that and
sarah we see with your character of
karna she's got this work shed she's in
at one point she's painting i have two
questions about this because they're
also these little dogs running around
too so what exactly is going on in that
workshop there's always posters too i
don't know if there's like easter eggs
or something and do you paint in real
life
um no i don't paint i even even when i i
did my first book was illustrated but i
can't draw so what i did was i took
pictures of my friends and i would trace
them so i can't i have literally very
little like sense when it comes to that
stuff but luckily when you're painting
an aura it's just
random whatever so
i would l i wish i could see or i tried
to be method and i tried to see the aura
in that scene but i couldn't um and i i
wish i could but we were filming in this
house um that was just very eclectic and
there were these dogs and james was just
very in the moment like these dogs are
great let's let's let's have them be
part of the scene and it was like so fun
because i love dogs i love every dog i
meet and so
i don't know it just added so much to it
and that was kind of the vibe on set it
was like let's see where we are and
let's make it let's make it happen and
i've never been on a set like this
before and so it was just it was i
couldn't have asked for a better first
set to be on
yeah it was really cool and it did add
so much to your character it was just
visually awesome and said a lot about
karna which i liked and again just great
job it looked like you really know to
paint so props um
lake your voice acting career is already
legendary it's soaring at this crazy
rate with black widow and what if and
poison ivy and harley quinn what i want
to know though are you as passionate
about these iconic characters as us
nerds are like are you feeling that deep
connection too because we're we're
loving how you're doing it but are you
feeling are you feeling that joy
okay
here's the truth i
g i get to know
um a lot of these iconic characters as i
play them um
in real time so
um it's kind of i think what when you
have someone a character like black
widow or you know poison ivy these are
so iconic um to the universes that they
come from
that you kind of have to go in not
overthinking what used to be or what was
and trying to just apply what you know
of it in real time right so i think i
try to do that and um
especially i mean poison ivy i sort of
like cr it just isn't a it's an
extension of myself um
her rye kind of um sarcasm and at this
point season three or whatever that were
we're just you know it's like they write
right to my mouth so that works out but
but yeah i've got um
just to speak to that not to overly
promote something else but the inside
voice is uh an audiobook that i'm doing
with malcolm gladwell's company uh
pushkit industries so
that comes out in november and that's
speaking all about how the voice can
wield all this power and um import
i love it and i'm excited to see you in
the voice acting hall of fame wherever
that is if there is one you're gonna be
there i can't wait it's gonna be like
number one there number one and uh
before i let you guys go sarah if you
give one tip for your incredible story
of just during the pantemic blowing up
from doing stand-up for so long what
would you say to people who feel like
giving up and they've been doing it for
a while with one thing you would say
um focus on
focus on what you find joy in you know i
want to give up every day every day i'm
like
my career is over you know every day but
for some reason i can't stop writing i
can't stop like auditioning i can't stop
looking for ways to tell stories and so
if there's something in you that you
just can't stop doing keep doing it you
know you don't have to quit your job or
anything like that but just follow that
thing that you can't stop doing and and
don't don't give up
i love it guys you heard all this magic
from lake and sarah and you get to see
them do magic in this film summer which
is in
theaters today thank you lake and sarah
for joining me and hope to see you guys
in the future thank you steve
bye